you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's a cool
composition by Nicolas Russell emo this
is the first composition I'm sharing by
him and his playlist this one was
published in 1928 it is white to move
and as usual I encourage you to pause
the video and spend some time as much
time as you need
trying to work this one out come back to
this video at a later stage for the
solution it's white to move and it's up
to you to try and find the best
continuation ok the solution here is
first off to not grab the pawn and let
me just quickly show why that is the
case it's because bishop takes the
knight and this is a draw with best play
white cannot win this the first move
must be work to GE one of the things I
liked about this composition is the
little bit of insight that we gained
about the rook and the knight and how
they interact or can interact with one
another by inserting this check we're
forcing the King to a square where the
knight can next move and give a check
you'll notice c7 is covered by inserting
this check the King must go to one of
these two squares one of these two light
squares same color squares the night the
knight can next move and give a check
can be seven Knights e5 just this alone
this little interaction between the rook
can be useful maybe in one of your own
games a knight would be attacking some
piece on one of these highlighted
squares and hitting with a fork that's
not the only interaction to be familiar
with but that's the first to know after
this night c5 move it's of course out of
the bishops way so that's nice white is
ready to maybe grab the pawn and
actually play a position where it is
rook and Knight versus the bishop black
must move and attack the knight from
this position if he doesn't
suppose he goes to a7 or c7 we simply
grabbed upon
this is a win for white therefore black
must approach the night by way of b6 or
c6 suppose king c6 the knight can't move
now and give a check however the rook
can now play to ca and this is the other
little interaction between the rook and
Knight to be familiar with what does
this move accomplishing well it's
pairing the threat black has on white
it's relieving the pressure with tempo
with an attack against the black king
and doing so in a way where black can
not react and to throw a punch back
black cannot move towards the rook in
other words and attack the rook because
of how the knight is simply guarding
those two squares so from this position
black I don't know pick your favorite
square let's say here Y can now pick up
the pawn and this will be a win so
suppose black attacks the knight by way
of b6 and this is really the main
continuation you needed to calculate
from the initial position supposing the
knight is attacked along a diagonal
sidestepping these ideas where the rook
gives a check and defends the night
along a file and what do we do now from
this position if we're grabbing the pawn
they grab the night and it's yet again a
draw so where do we go with the knight
is the big question there's a couple
squares Knight d7 is not working because
after King c7 what's the move the
Knights attacked black is threating
threatening to queen best is to maybe
just grab the pawn King takes tonight
and this is a draw the knight must go to
a4 and you may already be seeing a
pattern here with the night he started
out on a6 went to c5 a for this pattern
continues king b5 if you're going on the
same file rook to e8 and then we pick up
the pawn so black continues
to attack the night along a diagonal
Knight c3 Knight a two-night c1 and this
is the key idea to this composition
after king b2 or C - well if King C - we
could do this but suppose King 2b -
still following the same format along
this you know attacking the knight in
other words offered along a diagonal
here Knight here is now covered by the
bishop but this Knight is actually
indirectly defended how so only at this
point only after we have placed our
knight on the first ring can we
successfully to grab the pawn because
now after King takes Knight we have rook
to g1 which is a pin in next we will win
the bishop so I thought this I thought
that this composition was really neat
these the little interaction between the
rook and Knight for this I don't know
this little aesthetic idea here of the
the zigzagging of the night all the way
down to this first rank if you did not
come up with this solution how might you
have been able to do this well I mean
the trick here was to try and find a way
to maybe force the King to be on the
same rank or the same file as the bishop
in situations like that there is that
idea of maybe a fork by the rook or in
this case a pin and then win of the
bishop by the rook so as usual feel free
to leave any feedback to this video
share if you got the solution not or
whatever else you would like to share in
the comments comment section below as
usual I hope you enjoyed it and I'll
catch you in the next one that's all for
now take care bye
you